um
i mean it rubs quite often
okay
um
i know
and
um
i'm right here
all right so one of you guys needs to go
out i don't know
who is here um we have one two three
four five
six seven eight right
got here then you come in the next first
in the next group
yeah unfortunately
he's like
is
we need to move someone
we need to have one more person go out i
don't know who is here but apparently
uh
we're not removing a spot we just have
eight people seven is the absolute max
so who who was here last
year okay sorry
we got a lot of people starting quick
back there
got eight matt how are you doing um
um
yes
so can't have youtube but
um that's too much
can i get one of you to go over here for
now yeah do you mind doing that
and then we'll do i'm getting real here
with 70 ryan is only like six
um
thank you
and al um shingles gonna be behind you
on this ride
so if you can't
um
that's
uh
they should be
yeah the the it should be
uh you'll be here i'll like i'll go
there
okay the signature sandwich here
you're right put the chicken up a little
bit yeah
interior
the inconsistency and talent motivation
oh
literally the pictures came in and you
just kind of
seriously
location
we've kept those dinosaurs
is
i think happens
spot
great good afternoon i am delighted to
be
here with all of you and joined by our
speaker the chairman of the
judiciary committee uh congressman
takanawa will be our momentary
leader schumer the lead sponsor of the
equality act the senate senator merkley
and two of our greatest champions of
course senator brooker senator baldwin
today the house will take up and pass
for the second time
the equality act hr5 and we are really
excited to have the
incredible support of president biden
and his commitment to make the equality
act the law of the land
as you all know our country was the
first country founded on the principle
of liberty and justice for all
and we have made progress in that quest
we've stumbled sometimes but we've made
some progress
but the lgbtq community while having
made some progress continues to be in
this fight for full equality in most
states
members of the lgbtq community are at
risk of losing
an apartment being denied credit being
turned away from service on the jury
all because of who they are or who they
love every american deserves
respect and dignity and it's important
that the equality
come along because it will once and for
all ensure that lgbtq americans can live
lives
free of discrimination and in particular
it amends the existing civil rights
architecture
adds sexual orientation gender identity
to employment education
housing credit jury service public
accommodations and federal funding
it's a fully inclusive civil rights law
that will once and for all
make discrimination illegal in this
country finally
it's not a controversial issue anymore
83 of americans support
anti-discrimination legislature lbt
lgbtq americans
68 of republican voters so this is not a
controversial issue we've built a
coalition that ranges in everyone from
the u.s chamber of commerce to the aclu
and everyone in between
i know over 600 major organizations
hundreds of business leaders
representing some of the most important
companies in america
all uh support the equality act and i'll
end with
just a word in remembrance of our
extraordinary colleague the late john
lewis
who had a very critical moment in our
fight for the equality act
made certain that people understood the
urgency of this action and the
importance of doing this comprehensive
bill
and i hope in his honor we will finally
make the project the law of the land
and with that i'm delighted to introduce
the senate sponsor
the lead sponsor in the senate senator
so the equality act is all about freedom
president lyndon johnson said the
freedom is the right to share
fully and equally in american society it
is the right to be treated in every part
of our national life
as a person equal in dignity and promise
to all others
but today lgbtq americans
are not free they do not share full and
equally in our national life they are
not treated as individuals equal in
dignity and promise to all others
and 29 states it is still legal today to
discriminate
against americans because of who they
are and whom
they love in over half the states of the
union
lgbtq americans can be married in the
morning ejected from a restaurant at
lunch denied a mortgage or dismissed
from jury in the afternoon
evicted from their house that night it
is
way past time we change that way past
time
we pass a national equality act
together we all introduced this bill in
2015. in fact john lewis
was standing right here well not in this
room uh but across from the senate side
and i think as david mentioned that his
presence
was powerful then and as we think of him
it's powerful now he said
we should get in good trouble engage in
good trouble and we need a lot of good
trouble
this whole task in 2018
he had a powerful moment in may 17
2019 with consideration a passage
of the equality act in the us house of
representatives
and i applaud my house colleagues for
that tremendous
victory well done that was an awesome
moment but the leadership of the senate
at that same time
refused to hold a vote refused to hold a
debate
refused to hold a hearing on this
fundamental issue of freedom
but this year 2021 it's different we
have leadership in the house
and leadership of the senate that
supports
this vision of opportunity and equality
for all
we also have a tremendous number of
civil rights
partners that are taking us forward in
this effort naacp the human rights
campaign the lawyers committee for civil
rights a leadership conference on civil
and human rights a national urban
league that are working passionately and
diligently
to make sure we get this right
and this year is different because we
have a president joe biden who believes
in
the dignity and humanity of every
american
and it's different because we have more
senate sponsors and as david mentioned
we have more organizations we have more
businesses
we have more religious organizations
with us
at this moment my friends
it is time we end this dark history of
prejudice and discrimination
of the house speaker
welcome you over to the house side as
it's always a pleasure to welcome back
uh the distinguished now majority leader
of the senate back
senator and even more of a pleasure with
senator baldwin with you returning to
the house we always
such pride in her being in the house and
then when she went on to the senate as
well
and thank you for being here for this
very special occasion for all of us
senator booker uh welcome to the house
not necessarily back but welcome and
it's an honor to be here with you
mr chicano the chair of the veterans
affairs committee but a leader
in the equality caucus and of course our
chair of the
judiciary committee mr nadler who has
made so many things possible for us
honor to be with you
david cecillini is a person we're very
very proud
of and we thank you david for giving us
this
opportunity today and to you senator
merkley
senator merkley referenced to when we
were together
five years ago we were in the lbj room
as a matter of fact over on the senate
side
when this uh equality act was introduced
senator merkley the congressman
cicellini
or the lead sponsors but as senator
merkley mentioned
right there standing with them was john
lewis
and that was very important um again
we stood there with an icon of the civil
rights
movement in a room named for lg
lbj who had been the
sponsor who fought for and signed the
civil rights bill
the civil rights act is a pillar of
freedom in our country
it is not amended lightly so how proud
were we to have our beloved as i said
john lewis
and the congressional black caucus with
us on that day
uh as they gave their imprimatur to
opening up
the civil rights act to end
discrimination against the lgbtq
community our
the two sponsors of the bill have said
why
it shouldn't be necessary but why is it
necessary
and why it's important for us to act and
as we remember
john lewis's life we remember his words
spoken at the
parade the pride parade in atlanta
shortly after
being diagnosed with cancer we are one
people
one family we all live in the same house
and those words have been an inspiration
to us
in closing i just to please
and mrs talked about the outside groups
who are endorsing this legislation and i
want to thank
all of them for some it's the easiest
thing for others
it took a level of courage and shall we
say
fortitude to go forward but all of them
very important as we do our inside
maneuvering to get as many votes as
possible hopefully as bipartisan as
possible
the outside mobilization so it's
essential
to bring a trump to have a drumbeat
across america
uh for freedom for liberty and justice
for all
thank you all very much for being here
i'm going to excuse myself to go to the
floor as we have to build on the floor
right now
and i don't want to lose my time i don't
know who's in charge there but i don't
want to lose my time
with that i'm very pleased to yield to
the distinguished former member of the
house now
majority leader of the senate chuck
schumer and a champion
on this issue when he was in the house
and now as a leader in the senate
welcome
well thank you speaker pelosi it's great
to be here i want to thank all of my
colleagues
i want to thank my dear colleague
senator merkley for his steadfast
unrelenting passion on this issue
he reminds us every day how we have to
pass
the equality act because that's what
america is all about
and jeff has been a great leader here
and i thank him tammy baldwin
of course is one of our just outstanding
senators who's been right by jeff's side
pushing this bill and i want to thank
all of the house sponsors
and senator cory booker who is also at
mr merkley's side booking this
legislation
and i want to start by addressing head
on
some of the despicable comments made by
a few republicans
about trans people their attacks on
trans people and transgender community
are just
me mean and show a complete lack of
understanding
a complete lack of empathy they don't
represent our views and they don't re
represent the views of a majority of
americans
their despicable comments just make my
blood
boil with anger i didn't have a mask
to see my teeth gritting but that's why
we're here today
to talk about the equality that's why we
need it because of the hate out there
that gets in the way of the great
american dream of equality
in many ways the story of america has
been about making those words true
for all americans that's what brings us
here today
to reintroduce the equality act
in the senate essential
urgent long overdue that will move us
closer to a society where all americans
are equally treated under the law
even today the signs of discrimination
based on sexual orientation abound
from education to housing to family
planning from the workplace to adoption
to immigration
discrimination against lgbtq plus people
remains a serious problem that demands
congress's attention
congress must pass the equality act
so that lgbtq plus americans will no
longer have to face discrimination
in some of these most basic areas of
life
this legislation is personal for me
just six years ago lgbtq americans like
my daughter
won the legal right to marry who they
love
the equality act would make sure she can
continue
living her life with her wife with the
security and dignity
of knowing she won't face basic
discrimination because of who she is
so proud of them now
no american should ever face
discrimination because of who they are
and who they love
when the equality act passed the
congress last year it was a bipartisan
vote
yet for years leader mcconnell buried
the equality act
and other common sense bipartisan house
passed bills in his legislative
graveyard
those days are over those days are over
now with democrats in the majority the
senate will have the opportunity
to act on this critical civilized rights
legislation
i will use my power as majority leader
to put it on the floor and let's see
what everybody's saying
let's see where everybody stands i'm
hopeful
that just like in the house the equality
act will get republican votes
and pass the senate with bipartisan
support
and of course we now have an ally in the
white house with president biden who's
promised
to sign to make the equality act a
priority
discrimination against lgbtq americans
should
should be over once and for all
and democrats will fight tooth and nail
to make sure
that that happens and now i'm going to
turn it over to a dear friend
a fellow new yorker whenever it comes to
civil rights is at the forefront
congressman gerald now
thank you very much first let me begin
by thanking congressman celine for his
leadership
on this landmark legislation and
thanking speaker pelosi for her
steadfast support
of this legislation the equality act
represents one of the most significant
opportunities we have had to expand
civil rights in this country
in many many years for a long time
whenever the lgbtq community came to
congress
it was to defend their rights from the
defense of marriage act
don't ask don't tell even when we
considered ender
it was a major discussion as to whether
we can include protections for
transgender people
it is not lost on me that this is only
the second time in history
that congress has been able to consider
truly comprehensive
lgbtq civil rights legislation and i
could not be more proud
of the gains we have made to even be
standing here today
by freeing the lgbt community from
discrimination
the equality act makes america a little
more free
for everyone we cannot rely on the
supreme court to continue to advance
these issues for us
instead i expect that without the
equality act we will begin to see the
court
chipping away at the rights the lgbt
community has
already had acknowledged i am hopeful
that with majority leader schumer at the
helm of the senate
and president biden in the white house
we have a chance to see this signed into
law
and to take decisive action against the
discrimination faced by the lgbt
community nationwide
thank you very much uh and uh
like uh like speaker pelosi i have to
get back to the floor
uh for the debate but uh before i do
that
it's my pleasure to introduce uh senator
booker
it is so good that we are here today but
let's
be clear i would not be here today
if it wasn't for foot soldiers of
justice who fought to
push this body to pass
civil rights legislation that gave
me and other african-americans equal
dignity equal rights
and equal opportunity in this country
john lewis who has passed us bled
for that right and so now here we are
again
in a nation where the ideals of liberty
and equality and equal justice under law
are what we say
how we define our aspirations but we
still fall short we still live in a
nation
where the destructive darkness
of discrimination reigns
enshrines the laws of this land
to prevent equal dignity and equal
equality
to lgbtq america that is unacceptable
and so let us all feel the fierce
urgency of now
to not just see this legislation pass in
the united states house of
representatives
but for the sake of our ancestors and
generations to come
we may have passed in this senate and
get to the full get to the
best of the president united states
thank you and now i bring up uh
representative tacoma
thank you senator for reminding us of
the history
of civil rights and how it's worked for
the food soldiers
and and i remember being in my first
inauguration with president obama
and he invoked the image of seneca falls
soma and stonewall drawing that direct
line
of civil rights history of a nation
becoming a more perfect union
thank you to david cissolini for your
amazing
efforts of building this coalition it's
truly moving to be here
and i couldn't i mean chairman natalie
had to go back to the floor
but if you've ever had chairman natalie
tell you stories about
his conversations with bella i mean
jerry before lgbt members were really a
presence on the hill there was jerry
so we are so proud of him senator
merkley we're so proud of the work that
you've done
amazing work and i want to talk to you
more about
what we're going to talk about david
we're going to talk about we're going to
talk about here
all right almost 30 years ago i was
outed in my first
campaign for congress 27 years ago the
don't ask don't tell policy was
established in the military
25 years ago defense for the defense of
marriage act or doma was signed into law
and nearly 10 years ago don't ask don't
tell was repealed
seven years ago united in the united
states of the
windsor case it struck down doma uh
five years ago marriage equality became
the law of the land
and last year
and great nation cares about the dignity
and well-being of its most vulnerable
citizens
today as i go back to the floor and
thankfully the man that's going to take
her magic
the speaker is going to take our magic
bit on the floor to extend the amount of
time i have here
uh but i'm going to cast my vote i'll be
thinking of all the lgbtq activists who
marched
protested and built a movement to
protest the lives of lgbtq people to
expand our rights
i'm ready to go vote and i before i do
i want to introduce a pioneer who
a hero a shiro of mine i knew her when
she was back in the house and watched
her become
a senator with the integrity of being
elected to office
already out not coming out afterwards
um truly a trailblazer senator baldwin
well i want to start by uh thanking my
colleagues
for your courage and for standing up
and uh getting us to this moment it's i
feel like we should have a drum roll
because
soon the house will vote for the second
time to advance
the equality act um i appreciated
uh everybody's comments but i wanted to
also appreciate leader schumer's
comments with two regards one is
uh decrying and condemning
in the strongest of terms uh
the unfortunate and hateful remarks of
uh some of our colleagues and
uh the level of ignorance um
is unacceptable and
but i also hearken to the power of the
lgbtq
movement of visibility helping to change
hearts and minds and that's what this
long movement is about
i secondly appreciated leader schumer's
personal remarks you know he said it's
personal for me
and i will certainly say this is
personal for me too
not only as a member of the lgbtq
community but for my brief
time as a practicing attorney before i
was full-time
involved in public service
i'd be a patient to represent clients
in the lgbtq community who had faced
discrimination
at the workplace or in seeking housing
and i got to see how devastating that
can be
especially when the law falls short
in terms of protections in a majority of
states
and local jurisdictions lgbt americans
live without fully inclusive
non-discrimination laws
and can still face discrimination
because of who they are
or who they love and that's just wrong
and it's time to end this kind of
discrimination
against the lgbtq community all
americans should have the full freedom
of equality
that's why we're here today it's why i'm
so proud to stand with my colleagues
in the house and senate as the house
prepares
to pass the equality act we've been here
before
this year we have a pro-equality
majority
in both the house and the senate and we
have a present
with pro equality and prepared to sign
this bit
when it gets to his desk
so let's just get the job done
pass the equality act in the house and
senate let's send it to president biden
so he can sign it into law and we can
finally
provide full equality for every lgbtq
american across our country
david
uh so i do have to get back to the floor
but we have time at least for a few
questions
yes sir first thing uh and if i can ask
two questions real quick the first one
how do you get the 60 votes in the
senate that you need to pass this
and two uh off topics but uh chief
pittman today said that there was
there's a group
of militia members who were they have
been here on the six who were plotting
to perhaps
blow up the capital and express a desire
to blow up the capital around the state
of the union
i'm curious given all we've learned
about the response and the intelligence
failures
how safe you all feel and your
confidence level
uh in the security and the police i i'll
i'll defer
responding to that at another time if
that's okay i need to get to that
well i and i'm i hesitated to speculate
about the senate but i'll just say one
thing before i allow
or invite one of the senators to say but
you know it's the good old-fashioned way
we're going to make our case
our community is going to advocate with
members of the senate and we're going to
work hard until we get the votes
necessary to pass it there's no shortcut
for it
you know this is really an instance in
which the senate of the united states
has to catch up to the american people
as i mentioned it's overwhelmingly
supported republicans democrats and
independents by 83
of the american people another poll
shows the majority of voters in every
single state in america
support nondiscrimination protections
for the lgbtq community
so the biggest challenge we face is a
lot of people think it's already the law
when you tell them that someone can
you know get kicked out of the apartment
be denied service in a restaurant or not
be allowed to serve on a jury because of
their sexual orientation or gender
identity
they can't believe that's true and
that's because it it doesn't comport
with our basic
understanding of fairness and equality
so there's not a shortcut we're going to
work hard and get the votes and i
obviously the senators have some
tricks up to sleep about how we do that
you know your question immediately
assumes
that republicans will insist on on
poacher
60 votes to close debate and i was
thinking about how
when ted kennedy first brought the
employment on discrimination act to the
floor
back in i believe was 1998
we had no one in opposition
as for culture so we have a story here
of how dramatic the senate has changed
and i can tell you as one senator i do
not believe
that mitch mcconnell should be able to
veto
a bill the majority of the senate
supports that is about fundamental
human rights but we're not in
1998 and
we are still closer to 2013.
and in 2013 i took the employment
non-discrimination act of the four
and we did not have 60 votes and we had
to get 60 votes
and we worked it we worked it in
partnership
with our organizations that are civil
rights organizations that have huge
insight on the nuances of the language
and
the law and we worked it with our
colleagues and our colleagues shared
their stories
specifically would you want to tell
republican your colleagues about
you know they're talking about an
infringement religious liberties uh
bringing more lawsuits against churches
and places of worship
you know we were very careful in the
aquarium to ensure that
the religious exemptions which currently
exist remain undisturbed and so
what i would first say is in the same
way that all of the other areas of civil
rights law have established religious
exemptions
they would apply the same to the visions
of the equality the lgbtq community is
not looking for more protections
nor are we willing to accept class just
treat it the same as the all the other
protected classes
so religious organizations would still
enjoy the rights they have in terms of
ministerial functions
to limit their services and facilities
to members of their own congregation to
members of their own faith in good
standing
as they determine all those exemptions
which have been established
remain in place and so that's been an
argument that has been advanced but
we have two interests that are protected
here the right to relieve expression
the deeply held commitment ending
discrimination
equality act achieves both those things
can i just ask
versus bostock versus clayton county
decision
has basically extended to the entire
nation
one portion of the equality act relating
to
employment obviously a critical one but
by doing so has kept intact
uh current and existing religious
exemptions
um so that's now the reality in the
united states
and so i just want to
to underscore what david sweeney just
said that
we want no more nor shall should we
accept any luck thank you senator let me
take one more
um on the uh covered relief package
senator schumer this morning said it it
was uh
okay because i'm gonna run to the floor
i have one yes
uh uh chris stewart
on friday this is for all right
that bill very clearly is worse than
nothing
for the first time in our history would
actually put in federal statute
provisions that permit discrimination
against the lgbtq community
would be a tremendous step backward
which is why it's not supported by any
major lgbt organization all the major
lgbt organizations support the aquatic
the the steward bill is a
step back for full economy any problem
with democracy well i hope people who
are committed to equality for the lgbtq
community would not support that bill
because
it would put in statute and authorize
expressly discrimination against the
lgbtq community
thank you
thanks